what um what element of crypto do you
think is most analogous to the work that
you guys do right so you guys are very
quantitatively driven you're very aware
of human psychology and kind of the
market forces that are driven by that we
look at the crypto market you know and
you look at your business what's the
thing where you're like you know that
makes a lot of sense to apply this
approach - sure so the only thing that
we would have in our toolkit that I
would just sort of say was a natural for
crypto would be our momentum composite
you know most CPAs are momentum players
and when you look at the most successful
models in you know cotton and gold and
whatever their momentum models I mean
because you know there aren't really
fundamentals in crypto and so I would
think that momentum could be very
applicable mm-hmm and we have many
different types of momentum the one we
use the most is a composite of momentum
that includes standard deviation of
return so yet it penalizes the most
volatile and it gives more support to
the less volatile I could see that
working pretty nicely I mean it you know
if somebody said Jim you know I'm
putting a gun to your head and you got
to trade this crypto and you better make
some money I would definitely use the
momentum it's amazing